well in Minnesota a 15-story Condo
building is evacuated over significant
structural concerns this is in Rochester
about 75 miles Southeast of Minneapolis
nearly 200 people were forced out of
their homes Friday evening after fire
officials warned the building is not
safe this weekend crews will complete
structural Shoring work at the site this
comes just days after an apartment
building collapse in Davenport Iowa
recovery efforts resumed today for three
men who are feared Dead amid the rubble
Roxanna saberi has more
cruise on Friday started the delicate
process of removing debris from the
building's facade as search and rescue
workers from across the state scoured
the rubble looking for three people who
are now presumed dead that has allowed
us to move to the next phase of our
mission
Shoring securing the building for
control and Recovery Davenport Mayor
Mike Matson was asked whether any human
remains have been found we can't
disclose that yet but Brennan Colvin Jr
has Faith his father who lived in this
apartment is still alive because he's
really strong
I don't know if like you can survive
something like this do you think that
the city is doing all it can to find
your father I don't think Davenport is
there's some there's way more that they
could have done for years residents
documented falling bricks and cracked
walls and ceilings James Champion used
to live there and now lives next door I
felt very unsafe because how do you get
stuck in an elevator several times and
have to have the fire department what
did you see
um there was falling bricks in the front
and then in the back are you aware of
other buildings in the area with
structural problems and are you going to
send teams in now to take another look
at those as I've said before we're
constantly looking at that are there
going to be renewed efforts now yes
we're looking at every cycle of
inspection as Crews continued to work
out here there is no timeline yet for
demolition in the meantime a resource
center is set to open today to help
displace residents sign up for
assistance to get back on their feet for
CBS Saturday morning Roxanna saberi
Davenport Iowa